السلام عليكم ورحمه الله نفي في البدايه
ثم توعد ل الاستخبارات الامريكيه بهذا رد
دونالد ترامب على ما اصبح يعرف بازمه
الوثائق الاستخباريه الروسيه بشانه والتي
سربتها وسائل اعلام امريكيه وتحدثت عن
فضائح ومعطيات عن حياته
الشخصيه ترامب اقر ان روسيا ضال في قرصن
بيانات انتخابيه لكنه اعتبر ان تقدير
الرئيس بوتين ل يعد مكسبا ردود ورسائل
تحاول التقليل من حده الجدل الذي فجرته
ازمه الوثائق الاستخباراتيه عن المدى الذي
يمكن ان تبلغه استراتيجي موسكو في
علاقاتها بالولايات المتحده
الامريكيه انضم الينا الان من واشنطن
مراسل الجزيره محمد العالمي محمد هذه
الالباء التي تداولتها وسائل الاعلام
امريكيه ان احتمال ربما ان تكون روسيا
تمتلك وثائق او تسجيلات محرجه جدا كما قيل
للرئيس ترامب ماذا كان او اي صد كان لها
في الراي العام
الامريكي
وربما اخذت بالاهتمام الكامل للعاصمه
الامريكيه خاصه ان المؤتمر الصحفي الذي
كان ينتظر طويلا لرئيس المنتخب والذي كان
من المفترض ان يركز على الطلاق بين رجل
الاعمال دونالد ترامب
والرئيس الامريكي القادم مع امبراطوريته
العقاريه والتجاريه حتى لا يخلق انطباعا
بتضارب المصالح لكن احدث ه
فضيحه مع روسيا طغت على المؤتمر
الصحفي ما كان ايضا مثير الانتباه هو
توقيت التسريب الاخبار المتداوله في هذا
الملحق الذي اعطي حسب وسائل الاعلام
للرئيس المنتخب ولرئيس الحالي عن اخبار
غير مؤكده تفيد بان الروس ربما يمتلكون
معلومات قد يوظفون ه لابتزاز الرئيس
القادم المخابرات حسب وسائل الاعلام ابلغت
الرئيس القادم والرئيس الحالي انها غير
مؤكده لكنها ستحقق في الامر لكن التوقيت
ادى الى خسائر معنويه وسياسيه ولم يسيطر
فقط على المؤتمر الصحفي لرئيس المنتخب
ولكن ايضا على جلسه الاستماع للرجل الذي
اختاره لقياده
الخارجيه وجد الرئيس الامريكي المنتخب
نفسه في موقف دفاعي في اول مؤتمر صحفي
يعقده منذ فوزه في الانتخابات في مواجهه
احدث موجه من التهم ذات الصله بروسيا
اشارت الى ضروع مسكو المزعوم في تجميع ملف
معطيات فضائح حول الحياه الشخصيه
لترامب كما وجد الرئيس المنتخب نفسه في
مواجهه اجهزه المخابرات في بلاده والتي
سيراس خلال
ايام
قد تكون اجهزه الاستخبارات وراء عمليه
التسريب وان فعلت فسيكون ذلك وصمه عار
كبيره في سجلها لان وثائق من ذلك القبيل
ما كان ينبغي ان تكتب او يتم امتلاكها او
تسريبها ابدا ويرى كثيرون ان الرئيس
المنتخب يدفع ثمن اخطاء ارتكبها بنفسه
حينما كذب اجهزه استخبارات بلاده وبالغ في
الدفاع عن روسيا ورئيسها ويعتقد على نطاق
واسع ان التسريب الاخير قد يكون عمليه
انتقام محسوبه من الجواسيس الامريكيين ضد
رئيسهم القادم وفي محاوله لراب الصدع على
ما يبدو اقر دونالد ترامب لاول مره بان
روسيا هي التي تقف بالفعل وراء قرصنه
الانظمه الالكترونيه الامريكيه قبل ان
يضيف اشاده غير مسبوقه ايضا باجهزه
الاستخبارات في
بلاده روسيا التي تح حولت الى مصدر لا
يتوقف عن العطاء في توفير الفضائح
السياسيه في العاصمه الامريكيه بدءا من
محاوله روسيا المؤكده اختراق انظمه
معلوماتيه امريكيه خلال الانتخابات لترجيح
كفه المرشح الجمهوري دونالد ترامب الى
احدث الانباء غير المؤكده عن ضروع
الاستخبارات الروسيه في تكوين ملف عن
الرئيس المنتخب اصبحت ايضا موضوع اسئله
ملح
على مرشح ترامب لقياده الدبلوماسيه
الامريكيه ريكس ترسن القادم من شركه اكسان
موبل والقريب من موسكو والذي سبق له ان
اذان العقوبات الامريكيه على روسيا اذ طر
تحت تراكم الفضائح الى اعاده النظر في
تقييم علاقات بلاده بموسكو
اعتقد ان روسيا توجد الان في خانه الخصم
غير الودي وامل انلا تنتقل الى الى مرحله
العداء لان ذلك سيفرض نزاعا مباشرا بين
الطرفين لكن حتى في غياب النزاع المباشر
بين الطرفين من المتوقع ان تتواصل مضاعفات
الجدل الدائري حاليا على مستقبل العلاقات
مع روسيا في ظل الحكومه الامريكيه
الجديده استطلاعه الراي العام تفيد بان
مؤيدي دونالد ترامب لا يعيرون اهتماما
لهذا الموضوع لكن خصومه يعتقدون ان الم
واقف غير المسبوقه لرئيس منتخب ازاء روسيا
ستؤثر حتما على علاقه واشنطن بموسكو سلبا
او ايجابا وبغض النظر عما اذا كانت عمليه
الابتزاز صحيحه ام لا سيجد الفريق الحكومي
الجديد صعوبه في التعامل مع موسكو دون
مواجهه ريبه او حتى تهم
بالمحبه الرئيس الامريكي الم خب دونالد
ترامب بعد حوالي او قبل اسبوع من دخوله
البيت الابيض يدخل او يستعد لذلك الدخول
بعلاقه متازمه مع وسائل الاعلام ومع اجهزه
الاستخبارات وربما ان استمرت العلاقه
متازمه ربما قد تؤزم اجندته السياسيه في
نظر المراقبين الذين يعتقدون ان دونالد
ترامب عليه ان ينتقل من مرحله الحمله
الانتخابيه الى مرحله الاستعداد الفعلي
لحكم شكرا لك محمد العالمي مراسل الجزيره
من واشنطن نوسع النقاش اكثر ينضموا الينا
من مدينه بينساكولا في ولايه فلوريدا
مايكل برنت الضابط السابق في وكاله
الاستخبارات المركزيه والباحث في معهد
هيدسون ومن واشنطن هاردن لانج كبير
الباحثين في مركز التقدم الامريكي مرحبا
بضيفي الكريمين مايكل
بريجنت ماذا تقرا انت في توقيت
يب ما قيل ان روسيا ربما تمتلك وثائق او
تسجيلات مضره بصوره الرئيس المنتخب ترامب
او محرجه له سواء كانت هذه الوثائق او او
المحتويات محتوى هذه الوثائق صحيحا ام
مفبركا توقيت هذا
الامر شكرا على الاستف بالنسبه للتوقيت
نعلم ان الان الرئيس المنتخب يستعد لدخول
البيت الابيض وربما تم رفع الامر الى
مستوى السياسي وتم تاسيسه وهناك استخدام
للغه مشخصن بشكل كبير عندما نتحدث ايضا عن
وكاله الاستخبارات الامريكيه فهناك
مسؤولون تم تعيينهم من قبل اوباما وبعد
تسعه اي
سيغادرون هذه
الوكالات واعتقد انه تم تاسيس الموضوع
بشكل
مقصد ما تقصد بذلك هل هو تصفيه حسابات بين
الوكاله وترامب ام بين الاداره السابقه
وترامب
ان هذا هو تاسيس للامر هذا التقرير لا
يستهدف طبعا التخلص من الرئيس لكن كان
بالامكان التاكد والتحقق من هذا التقرير
وهذا ما يجعل التقرير كما قلت مسيسا بشكل
كبير اداره ترامب كانت تقول عن هذه
التقارير في البدايه انها تق قير كاذبه
وتقارير غير صحيحه ولكن الامور تغيرت كان
هناك ايضا حديث بشكل كبير عن مجموعه من
الملفات الاخرى
وهناك تمجيد
للروس في البدايه وما كان على ترامب ان
يقوم به اتجاه موسكو سواء كانت سيد هاردن
لان سواء كانت هذه التسريبات المزعومه
صحيحه ام مفبركه الى اي حد هذا الامر قد
يؤثر على صوره
الرئيس المنتخب الذي هو مقبل على دخول
البيت الابيض بعد ايام وعلى موقفه ايضا في
سواء في التع مع ادارته او مع النخبه
السياسيه والمؤسسات
الامريكيه اعتقد اننا يجب ان ننتظر لنرى
هذه التاثيرات تاثيرات طويله الامل امد
بمساله كونها سياسيه نعم سيكون هناك تاثير
سياسي لاننا خاصه في مساله انتقال القوى
اعتقد ان رد
فعل الفوري ان المعلومات كانت تنتشر
ومعروفه منذ وقت واذا تم استخدامها بطريقه
سياسيه لربما تم اطلاقها قبل الانتخابات
يبدو ان هنالك شعور من قبل القياده في
الاستخبارات وليس فقط اعطاء ايجاز
لقائد للرئيس الحالي والرئيس المنتخب
وايضا للاجهزه الاستخبارات من اجل اطلاق
نوع من التحقيق لهذه
المزاعم خاصه بعد ان يتم انتقال السلطه في
حقيقه الامر لا ارى ان هنالك اي شيء خطا
اعتقد ان
هنالك اشياء سلبيه في مساله اثاره هذه
الامور واعتقد انها يجب ان يتم التحقق بها
لانها بعضها المزاعم تبدو انها فيها
الكثير من اللغط ويجب ان يتم ايضاح الامر
امام الشعب الامريكي وخاصه مساله القلق من
نوع تواطئ بين روسيا من جهه
وايضا حمله ترامب وفريق هذا الامر يجب ان
لا يتم الكشف عنه بشكل كبير طيب كيف يمكن
اذا تقييم الانعكاسات والاضرار داخليا على
ترامب
وادارته مع تداول هذه المعطيات التي يفترض
ان تتضح صورتها او عدم صحتها لاحقا والتي
تشير اذا ثبتت الى تحول العلاقه مع موسكو
الى ما يشبه الابتزاز والاخضاع
وليس مجرد دعم ترامب في
الانتخابات من جهه احدى الجهات لا نعرف
اذا ما كان الروس يمتلكون اي شيء لابتزاز
الرئيس ترامب هنالك مزاعم وتم اعلام نشر
المعلومه حول هذا الامر على على المستويات
اعتقد ان نقطه القلق التي ربما موجوده عند
موجوده عندي هي العلاقه بين الاستخبارات
وبين الرئيس المنتخب وفريقه واليوم في
المؤتمر الصحفي فان الرئيس المنتخب اشار
على انها هذه الاساليب التي كان وشبهها
باساليب التي تستخدمها استخدمها هتلر
والنازيين واعتقد ان هذا الامر اثار نوعا
من العدائيه وهذا ويخلق نوعا من المشاعر
والاجواء التي لا نريدها ان تكون موجوده
الان طيب سيد ماكل جنت يعني بعد الحديث عن
تدخل روسيا في الانتخابات
الامريكيه هذه القضيه بالتاكيد تطرح
التساؤل حول التوجه الروسي الان اتجاه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه رغم ان ترامب
كثيرا ما تحدث بلغه مرنه وبنوع
من المديح اذا شئنا ان نقول لبوتين كيف
يمكن قراءه هذا التوجه الروسي الان في
اداره الصراع استخباراتيا مع واشنطن
التجسس القرصنه والاختراق ثم اذا صحت هذه
التسريبات الاخيره
الابتزاز اود فقط العوده الى ما قاله
ضيفكم
[موسيقى]
الاخر الاستخباراتي او موظفوا الاستخبارات
كانوا ايضا يشتكون من التاسيس وكالات
الاستخبارات الحديث حما يريد ان يسمعه
اوباما حول ايران وحول تنظيم الدوله وهذه
امور كانت طبعا واضحه انا عملت في
المؤسسات الامريكيه
وكثير من الاشخاص كانوا يشيرون
لروسيا كعدو للولايات المتحده اليوم
الامور تغيرت اليوم لدينا فرصه
ل متابعه روسيا لما حدث في حلب
واستهداف المدنيين
وايضا احتلال جزير شبه جزيره القرم وما
تقوم به روسيا ايضا
في اوكرانيا وطبعا هذه القرصنه تاتي ليس
فقط من روسيا من الصين من كوريا من
اسرائيل ومن دول اخرى كان على اوباما ان
يتنبه لهذه الامور حتى قبل الانتخابات
الان الامور اصبحت ما حط الحديث بعد
الانتخابات لذلك اقول بان الموضوع هو
مسيز الان طبعا الكثيرون لم يكونوا سعيدين
بنتيجه الانتخابات وعندما نتحدث حول
الهجمات
برن تقول الموضوع مسيس يبقى يبقى ان هذا
الموضوع هو اثر في في صوره الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه في صوره اجهزتها وايضا
في صوره رئيسها المنتخب المقبل وهيبه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه في علاقتها مع
روسيا وهنا سؤال اخير للسيد هاردن لانك من
المستفيد اذا في نهايه المطاف من هذا
التسريب المسيء لكل هذه الاطراف ولا يبدو
ان هناك ربما يعني رابحا من هذا
الصراع اعتقد انك محق ان الجميع خاسر في
هذا الموقف هنالك نوع من الجدل حول
التفاصيل التي حول الاشياء التي جرت في
فندق في موسكو وكان تحديث عن التواطئ بين
الحمله الانتخابيه
والكرملين ليس ايا من هذه المزاعم
تخدم صوره الشعب الامريكي وامريكا لكن
هنالك ايضا يجب انه يتم تفحص مصداقيه
الحمله
وحمله حمله الرئيس والرئيس نفسه وايضا
عصابه الثما الثمانيه ما يسمى عصابه
الثمانيه التي تتكون من اطراف من الحزبين
اعتقد ان العلاقه الاساسيه التي يجب ان
ننظر اليها هي بين الرئيس المنتخب وفريقه
وايضا الاستخبارات وربما يجب ان نبقي على
انه تكون هذه العلاقه قويه ومتينه ومما
يحدث الان يجب ان لا يؤثر هذا الامر على
هذه العلاقه في نفس الوقت يجب علينا ان
نصفي الاجواء فيما يتعلق بهذه المزاعم من
من مثير الاهتمام ان نرى الرئيس ترامب
للمره الاولى الروس يعترف انهم قد يكون
الروس وراء هذه عمليات القرصنه وهذا الامر
شكل تغيرا فيفه في نعم وهذا كان لافتا
بعدما كان ينفي ذلك السيد هاردن لانك شكرا
لك شكرا لهارد لان كبير الباحثين في مركز
التقدم الامريكي من واشنطن كما نشكر من
ولايه فلوريدا مايكل برجين الضابط السابق
في وكاله الاستخبارات المركزيه والباحث في
معهد هيدسون بهذا نصل نهايه الحصه شكرا
لكم والى اللقاء بحول الله